when i'm thinking about this question of
well what is a cup and let's forget
about it that is natural language let's
just imagine we're talking what is an
atom what is an atom and then we say
well we don't know exactly what an atom
is and then i wonder well what
explanation could one possibly give
that would satisfy someone so that they
wouldn't say well we don't know what
that is so let's say we explain the
atoms in terms of something else then we
can say that again and again is there
something at the bottom that we can say
okay now we understand it now we know
what that is
well we've known
since the 17th century
that there isn't going to be any
any
answer to that question
that we can
accept with certainty
empirical questions
we can try to find
the best theories
the best explanatory theories
but we can never be certain that they're
true that's been understood since the
17th century
since the collapse of
the mechanical philosophy
so we just have to live with that
we live in a world in which we can seek
best explanations
but uh that's it now maybe it's possible
to go further
maybe
leibniz's
principle of sufficient reason
can carry us further
leibniz
argued
the familiar phrase is we live in the
best of all possible worlds but there's
a much deeper theory behind it
saying that nature
necessarily
constructs the best possible world
nothing else is possible
if
you hang a string of beads they're going
to go in a perfect form not they're not
going to go in a square
because nature always
necessarily
seeks the simplest solution
and then there's a background for that
in the principle of sufficient reason
and so on well if that's correct and it
it's had it's been an amazingly
productive idea
every in fact galileo had said something
similar but
more loosely said
the world is
nature is simple and our task is to
prove it
that's uh
leiden said a much deeper theory and a
mathematical theory and some of the
great mathematicians worked on this
to try to show that it's got to be true
and if you look at
the results of the sciences
anywhere you understand something it's
true
many great scientists have come and
commented on this
said the mysterious thing
is not that there are laws
but they're always simple laws
and if they're not simple laws we find
they're wrong
well leidness had a general argument to
that effect
and if you can
sometimes it's called the magical
property of science
always
if you get anything like the right
answer it's always the simplest answer
as i say leibniz had
arguments for that and the great
mathematicians of the 17th century
worked on it to try to prove it
uh
descartes others
the uh
if that's true
then
there's something
that should we should be certain about
whatever is simplest is going to be true
but that leaves a lot of questions open
like our understanding of simplicity
plus
the impact of the law of sufficient
reason
so we're in
difficult territory but the simplest
point to say is we just can't be
confident
about our
empirical conclusions
actually that
goes back a little bit to the first
question you asked
uh
we can't assume
that because something is needed
by our flawed theories
that it's therefore necessarily true
that we can't because our theories are
flawed and we know it